human beings have always realized that
certain things are longer than other
things for example this line segment
looks longer than this line segment but
that's not so satisfying just to make
that comparison you want to be able to
measure you want to be able to quantify
how much longer the second one is then
the first one and how do we go about
doing that well we define a unit length
we define a unit length so if we make
this our unit length this we say this is
one unit then we could say how many of
those lengths are each of these lines so
this first line looks like it is we can
do one of those units and then we could
do it again so it looks like this is two
units while this third one looks like we
can get to see that's one to three of
the units so this is three of the units
and right here I'm just saying units
sometimes we've we've made conventions
to define a centimeter where the unit
might look something like this and it's
going to look different depending on
your screen or we might have an inch
that looks something like this or we
have might have a foot that I won't be
able to fit on this on the screen based
on how big I've just drawn the inch or
meter so there's different units that
you could use to measure in terms of but
now let's think about more dimensions
this is literally a one dimensional case
this is 1d why is it one dimension well
I can only measure measure I can only
measure length but now let's go to a 2d
case let's go to two dimensions where
objects could have a length and a width
or width and a height so let's imagine
two figures here that look like this so
let's say this is one of them this is
one of them and notice it has a width
and it has a height or you could view it
as a length in it or you could view it
as a width and a length depending how
you want to view it so let's say this is
one figure right over here and let's say
this is the other one so this is the
other one right over here try to draw
them reasonably well now once again now
we're in two dimensions and we want to
say well how much how much in two
dimensions space is this taking up or
how much area are each of these two
taking up well once again we could just
make a comparison this second if you
viewed the miss carpets or rectangles
the second rectangle is taking up more
of my screen than this first one but I
want to be able to measure it so how
would we measure it well once again we
would define a unit square instead of
just a unit length we now have two
dimensions we have to define a unit
square and so we might make our unit
square and the unit square we will
define as being a square where its width
and its height are both equal to the
unit length so this is its width is one
unit and its height is one unit and so
we will often call this one square unit
oftentimes you'll say this is one unit
and you put this two up here this
literally means one unit squared and
instead of writing unit I could have
this could have been a centimeter so
this would be one square centimeter but
now we can use this to measure these
areas and you say well how many just as
we said how many of this unit length
could fit on these lines we could say
how many of these unit squares can fit
in here and so here we might take one of
our units squared and say okay it fills
up that much space or we need more to
cover all of it well there we'll put
another unit square there we'll put
another unit square right over there
we'll put another unit square right over
there
Wow for unit squares exactly cover this
so we would say that this has an area of
four four units four square units or
four units squared now what about this
one right over here
well here let's see I could fit one two
three four five six seven eight and nine
so here I could fit nine nine units nine
units squared let's keep going we have
we live in a three-dimensional world why
restrict ourselves to only one or two so
let's go to the 3-d case and once again
when people say 3d they're talking about
three dimensions they're talking about
the different directions that you can
measure things in here there's only
length here there's length and width
Thor width and height and here there
will be width and height and depth so
once again if you have if you have let's
say a an object and now we're in three
dimensions where in the world we live in
that looks like this and then you have
another object that looks like it looks
like this that looks like this it looks
like this second object takes up more
space more physical space than this
first object does it looks like it has a
larger volume but how do we actually
measure that and remember volume is just
how much space something takes up in
three dimensions area is how much space
something takes up in two dimensions
length is how much space something takes
up in one dimensions but when we think
about space we're normally thinking
about three dimensions so how much space
would you take up up take up in the
world that we live in so just like we
did before we can define instead of a
unit length or unit area we can define a
unit volume or a unit cube so let's do
that let's define our unit cube and here
it's a cube so all of its its length
width and height are going to be the
same value so my best attempt at drawing
a cube and they're all going to be one
unit so it's going to be one unit high
one unit one unit deep and one unit one
unit wide and so to measure volume
because a well how many of these unit
cubes can fit into these different
shapes well this one right over here and
you won't be able to actually see all of
them I could essentially break it down
into so let me see how well I can do
this so that we can count them all it's
a little bit harder to see them all
because you're there's some cubes that
are behind us but if you think of it as
two layers so one layer would look like
this one layer is going to look like
this so imagine two things like this
stacked on top of each other so this
one's going to have one two three four
cubes now this is going to have two of
these stacked on top of each other so
here you have eight unit cubes
or you could have eight units cubed
volume what about here well if we try to
fit it all in if we try to fit it all in
let me see how well I could draw this
well I can draw this it's going to look
something like this it's going to look
something like this obviously this is
kind of a rough drawing and so if we
were to try to take this apart you would
essentially have three you'd have a
stack of three sections that will each
look something like this my best attempt
at drawing it three sections that would
look look something like what I'm about
to draw so it would look like this
so three if you took three of these and
stacked them on top of each other you
would get this right over here and each
of these have one two three four five
six seven eight nine cubes in it nine
times three you're going to have
twenty-seven twenty-seven cubic units in
this one right over here so hopefully
that helps us think a little bit about
how we measure things especially how we
measure different things in different
number of dimensions especially in three
dimensions when we call it volume